you don't think that the desire is the
determining factor for the ontology of
the embryo the embryo is human that's
that's not within question it is a human
embryo so then why wouldn't you use
anthropomorphizing language why wouldn't
you refer to it in human language
because language is often emotional and
pregnancy is an emotional state for
someone to be in and as a medical
professional you have to be conscious of
the way that your words affect the
patient and so you would lie to the
patient because you're just lying well
you said it is lying because you said
the baby or fetus or whatever you want
to say is a human and you said the word
baby is humanizing language so you're
describing the human being with
humanizing language unless you say that
the emotions of the of the pregnant
mother are such that you don't want to
describe the human being in humanizing
language and so you describe the human
being in dehumanizing language how do
you and you're doing it knowingly you've
just admitted the baby's human yeah how
would you describe that other than
telling a lie